[Music]
[Music]
i wasn't originally going to talk about
this topic but i've been seeing a lot of
confusion around how the expertise
system will actually work
while there are a few details that may
not be 100 clear reading between the
lines i think we can safely assume the
answer
so in this video i'm going to attempt to
explain what we know so far as clearly
and simply as possible
it kind of brings me back to my beginner
guide videos that i used to make years
ago
i promise you this won't just be a video
where i'll read through the intelligence
annex page but i will be using it to
help me break down what i'm talking
about so bear with me
so what is expertise
expertise is a new feature coming out in
the major update we'll be seeing for the
division 2 early next year
this is a new way for us to level up our
weapons gear and skills
agents will now have an expertise level
similar to our watch level but probably
not displayed on the hud screen in the
same way
through gaining expertise levels you
will be acquiring points that you can
use to increase the grade of your gear
with the optimization station allows you
to upgrade your gear towards its max
value using your expertise points to
increase the grade of an item will
increase the max value
now this is where it starts to get a
little confusing for some in order to
increase your expertise level you need
to increase the proficiency rank of your
weapons gear and skills
each individual item type in the game
will have its own proficiency rank to
level up
the more items you rank up the higher
your expertise will grow
to increase the proficiency of an item
use them in combat
have them equipped while gaining kill xp
equipping several items from a brand or
set will increase the proficiency points
earnings for this specific type
donating matching items
donating materials
the catches you can't just keep leveling
the proficiency rank of the same gear
forever every item type has a max
proficiency rank of 10.
once this is achieved you'll no longer
be earning xp from this item towards
your expertise level
so for the most efficient gains towards
your expertise level you would try to
change out your gear and weapons as soon
as they have reached maximum proficiency
to run something that hasn't been
leveled
like i mentioned above the gaining of
expertise level will provide you with
points to upgrade an item
depending on the item type the upgrade
gained from using one of these points is
one of the following
weapons one percent increase to base
damage
gear one percent increase to base armor
value
skills one percent increase to base
damage healing status effect duration
but they made sure to note that these
values are a work in progress
so for balancing purposes they may be
tweaked before release
summing up gear weapon and skills now
have a new ranking system that we can
use to level up through using them in
normal gameplay
leveling up items will increase your
overall expertise level in turn granting
you something that you can use to
increase the base stats of an item of
your choosing
these couple of lines are quite
important to note
for each level of expertise players gain
increased ability to upgrade an item
using materials
players may upgrade any given item as
many times as their current expertise
level this basically means that you can
pump all of the upgrade points into a
single piece of gear in theory
sadly all i can see is some potential
balancing issues coming from this
imagine a striker drone that could mow
down everything on the field
a sniper build with insane levels of
damage though to be fair this probably
wouldn't be a good use of the upgrades
any half decent sniper build can already
kill most enemies in one shot but the
numbers would look pretty impressive
i'm sure they're already considering
this and are working through the testing
as we speak
they might add depreciating gains with
each additional point
or introduce a cap on the number of
upgrades a single piece can have
maybe the points received will be locked
into an item category forcing you to
upgrade gear weapons and skills rather
than just focusing on one type
naturally there is a finite number of
items so there will be a max expertise
level but as new items are added that
max level will increase
we also need to think about the fact
that we don't know how many items need
to be leveled to max proficiency in
order to gain an expertise level again
i'm sure this is something that they're
still working out
i actually think this isn't a bad idea
or at the very least it will be more
widely accepted than simply raising the
max gear score level
people who like to grind will have a lot
more to do
those who like to min max will have a
little bit of extra to work on to get
the absolute best out of their build
i certainly don't think this will affect
build diversity and i actually don't
think this was the intention
while you'll be using weapons and gear
that you don't usually touch for a small
amount of time when they're at max
proficiency it's likely they'll be
tossed aside again returning to your
favorites
your most used build will be getting
stronger but everything else will stay
as it is
as i said at the beginning we don't have
all the information on this yet just
what was in the intelligence annex but
the discussions i've been seeing were
shown that a lot of people weren't quite
understanding
i'll post the article in the description
if you haven't checked it out yet
i suspect balancing and testing is
likely to affect the outcome of some of
the points raised so expect some changes
before next year
i'll probably remake this once the
update has been released and the finer
details have been sorted
but as always until more content is
added to the game this won't be enough
to have people return on its own
we need to remember though these
intelligence annex releases are just
giving us small snippets of what's
coming
these annex updates don't represent the
bulk of what we'll be seeing
anyway i hope you've cleared up a few
things with this video if you have any
further questions regarding expertise
and how it currently stands let me know
in the comments i'll do my best to get
back to you
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
you